euh merci c'est important de le rignaler
euh les Chéries ce soir on a décidé de
rajunir de 30 ans euh bon pour vous
bah toi toi ça veut dire tu vois tu vas
à peine atteindre les 90
euh bon alors je vous dis il y a des
surprises de fous ce soir qui vont
arriver dans un instant mais juste avant
on va revenir sur les moments les plus
forts de cette décennie et dans les
moments les plus forts il y avait
malorinaataf la star des années 90
actrice dans la série le miel et les
abeilles à la fin de la série à succès
Malori a vécu une véritable descente aux
enfers jusqu'à se retrouver à la rue et
perdre la garde de ses enfants ça a été
une histoire incroyable elle va venir
nous la raconter dans un instant avec
Jean-Luc azoulet bien entendu son
producteur mythique mon ami Jean-Luc
alors pour ceux qui ne la connaissent
pas malorine ATF est devenue une superst
grâce à la série le miel et les Abes al
le miel et les abaes c'était très simple
il y avait Malori et il y avait tous les
mecs qui étaient en fait sur ses côtes
voilà c'est un petit peu comme voilà
comme Gilles Verdez aujourd'hui euh non
mais c'est vrai un c'est un petit peu ça
c'est en 92 elle jouait le rôle de Lola
euh regardez on a un extrait du premier
épisode on la retrouve tout de suite
après avec Jean-Luc elle sera avec nous
merci à vous deux regardez
merci tu m'as toujours appris que la
fortune appartenait aux gens qui se
levaient tôt et j'ai bien l'intention
d'être
riche ça va ma chérie mieux qu'hier soir
h je suis vraiment désolée hein je sais
pas ce qu'il aur a pris la tête que j'ai
fait en les voyant hier soir avec Anne
et toi remarque la tête qu'ils ont fait
quand ils t'ont vu arriver avec Henri
tuétait pas mal non plus
hein qui est avec
nous comédienne et
chanteuse et jeanluc
Aoul qui est pour moi Jean-Luc aoulet
qui est pour moi la la la plus grande
star de télévision française je dis non
mais c'est vrai le plus grand
producteur plus
grand le plus gros surtout non non non
non arrête arrête al ce soir j'ai
commencé chez lui oui c'est vrai tu
étais tout petit ouais j'ai commencé
chez lui hein je me rappelle j'écrivais
des lettres ouais Jean-Luc j'aimerais
bien travailler avec vous tout ça et un
jour je suis allé à chez AB Production
je peux te dire j'étais comme un fou
j'avais écrit une série avec Jean-Luc
c'est Jean-Luc qui m'a donné ma chance
le
premier mais je suis très fier de ça
d'Urs non mais c'est vrai tu es un amour
bah tu vois tuis tu vois tu tu as vu le
mal que tu as fait au gens de me mettre
à l'antenne
oui ah bah ils ont on se demandait d'où
ça venait ben mant voilà on sa c'est lui
qu c'est lui le monstre c'est lui qui a
cr c'est Lui qui a créé le monstre c'est
Lui qui a créé le monstre on fait du
bien aux gens parce que pour une fois on
leur dit la vérité on les amuse
exactement tu as raison la seule chose
quiil faut c'est tout c'est les abusés
c'est vrai que il nous compare souvent à
à ce qui se passait aussi et moi je me
rappelle le club doroté et cetera et
c'est vrai que c'était il y avait il y
avait la même c'était voilà c'était
c'était les gens ça ça ça ça ça ça
rendait fou les gens mais parce qu'on
les abusait parce qu'on parce qu'on ne
se prenait pas au sérieux parce qu'on
faisait un spectacle pour eux pour que
les gens se sentent bien chez eux pour
que les enfants soient fédéré just on
fédérer les enfants il y avait pas
différents enfants tous les enfants
étaient fédérés autour des descès animés
autour de doroté et maintenant chacun
est dans son coin et on Fa on a fait un
beaucoup pour la Fédération des Français
je c'est on en reparle tiens j'en
reparler parce que c'est c'était sgolen
royale à l'époque he qui avait déposé en
plus est chez nous maintenant c'est goen
je vais lui en parler je on va va la
prochaine fois qu'elle vient je vais lui
parler on va sortir les dossiers on va
sortir les dossiers exactement Malori
merci d'être avec nous vous savez que
quand j'étais bah je je vous regardais
moi je vous regardais tout le temps
j'étais comme un ouf sur l'Ola comme
tous les garçons on était tous amoureux
de l'Ola non mais c'est vrai donc merci
d'être avec nous ce soir euh comment ça
va déjà vous avez l' bien en forme ben
je je je poursuis mon petit bonhomme de
chemin je me redresse petit à petit j'ai
traversé vraiment l'enfer le purgatoire
j'avais des choses à expier je les ai
expié avec ma croix dehors sur les
bouches de métro c'était vraiment j'ai
j'ai vécu un enfer parmi vous mais comme
je disais j'étais enfermé à l'extérieur
c'est ça enfermé à l'extérieur va parler
et et n'ayant pas la capacité de
demander de l'aide parce que j'avais
l'impression que j'allais gêner les gens
et que j'allais les les troubler dans
leur quotidien parce que chacun porte sa
petite croix au quotidien et je me
disais je vais pas leur ramener la
mienne qui qui est costaud et qui est je
je j'étais persuadé que je pouvais m'en
sortir seul ce qui n'était pas le cas
alors on vient de voir ta première
apparition dans La Cite comm à succès
donc le miel et les abeilles à l'époque
tu n'as que 20 ans comment tu arrives
dans la série ben je fais c'est mon
premier casting
ouaisis de faire la puoc-a la Seu pub
coc-olaour en France et jeis mon prier
cas chez AB Production je ne savais même
pas que c'était pour une série je
pensais que c'était pour une pub et 4
jours après il me rappelle à la maison
et je les ai pas cru donc ils me disent
il faut venir faire des essais de
costume j'ai dit oui oui bien sûr je
vais venir oui oui oui j'ai raccroché
mon copain de l'époque me dit qui c'est
je ces personnes c'est une erreur de
numéro et je ne me suis pas présenté et
3 jours après il me rappelle en me
disant mais pourquoi n'êt-vous pas venu
essayer les costumes je dis mais vous
parlez de quoi là il me dit mais vous
êtes engagé vous êtes rôle principal
dans une série pour TF1 donc j'ai j'y ai
pas cru j'ai tout simplement pas cru
inroable incroyable alors euh tu as
toujours rêvé d'être actrice depuis
toute petite j'étais fan des films des
années 4050 moi les film en noir et
blanc de
dreilleer
de Visconti j'étais j'étais une
affitionadose de cinéma mais je pensais
pas que j'avais les compétences et les
qualités pour faire ce métier et puis la
réelle la vie on a décidé autrement
alors en 93 tu deviens tellement
populaire qu'une grande marque de soda
te choisit pour être la vedette de de sa
publicité
regardez ça va trop chaud tiens essaye
ça tourn
[Musique]
généraleô que je l'avais jamais vu
j'avais jamais vu la pub merci non mais
envoyant cette pub on cherch une très
jolie fille pour M les abeilles un qui
avait été très long et j'ai appelé je
lui dit une fille dans la pub de
Coca-Cola elle l'a appelé tout de suite
et voilà comment c'est venu mais tu sais
que le même truc avec Daniel
morou j'ai dit une fille dans la pub
d'Amar et on l'a ré direct je te jure
direct je te
comprends regarde elle est là
aujourd'hui C regarde elle va tous nous
enterrer
93 donc tu es au top de ta carrière je
me rappelle tu avais chanté au club de
roté le titre les filles c'est très
compliqué oui de Pierre Grillet qui
composait qui écrivait pour Vanessa
Paradis ouais je te confirme les filles
c'est très
compliqué il y en a pas mal là ouais
mais c'est il y a toujours des morceaux
de choix chez vous hein oui maisme les
plus compliqués sont pas là ce soir euh
actrice et chanteuse tu multiplies les
apparitions
[Rires]
regarde très
compliqué contrairement aux
apparence pense à toi en
permanence pense même qu'il y a
[Musique]
urgence contrairement à vos
apparences donc tu chantes tu chantes tu
joues tu tu joues dans une série à
succès tu es au top tu kiffes ta vie à
ce momentl ou pas j'ai pas tellement le
temps ça va tellement vite donc je
m'amuse je sortais la nuit moi j'allais
en boîte de nuit je dansais 10 15 heures
par semaine dans des boîtes de nuit
j'avais une vie sociale qui était hyper
développé donc j'avais le miel je faisis
jouer au théâtre le soir puisque très
rapidement j'ai j'ai joué au théâtre au
bout de 3 mois où j'avais été engagé
diffusé sur TF1 j'ai j'ai joué une pièce
avec Jean-Christophe barque qui depuis
est devenu très connu donc j'avais une
vie qui allait à 100 à l'URE c'était des
interviews toute la journée je signis tu
gagnais beaucoup de sous pas tellement
j'avais refusé une augmentation même
c'est vrai tu veux pas venir travailler
chez
moi tu avais refusé une augmentationà
toi que ça arrive
quoiugation c'est pour numéro elle é
exceptionnel tu sais non mais je te jure
non mais c'est incroyable moi jamais il
refuse
B vous nen plus Cyr vous êtes un beau
parti
Cyril n'écoutez pas tout ce qu'on dit
Jean-Luc sait que j'ai quelques
difficultés en ce moment je je sais oui
alors un an plus tard il y a eu cette
séquence hein que voilà tu te rappelles
tu chantes ton single flur sauvage je
vais pas passer la séquence l'accident
de de culotte comme on l'a appelé voilà
la robe se soulève les téléspectateurs
découvent tu ne portes pas de culotte ça
comment tu le vis à ce moment-là parce
que est-ce que c'était un espèce de buzz
de l'époque c'est ça attends attends
attends je remets les choses au point ah
vas-y il y avait quatre images sur 25
images par seconde où on n'ercevait
qu'elle n'avait pas de culotte donc
aucun téléspectateur n'a vu ça c'est
impossible à voir c'est quelqu'un qui a
a fait un arrêt sur image qui a regardé
ça image par image et qui a donné ça
mais impossible de le voir il y avait
quatre images en tout on les a compté he
parce que on nétait pas au courant nous
personne aperçu quand l'histoire est
sortie on a vérifié il y avait quatre
images où on apercevait avec des caméras
qui n'est pas de la ha définition une
ombre qui montrait qu'elle peut-être
n'avait pas de culotte mais c'était pas
du tout le scandale énorme que ça a créé
alors tu sais que celui qui a sorti les
images é à côté de toi c'est Jean-Michel
mer vous avez un LyX
jeanmichelou pas alors en 96 tu intègres
la série Sous le soleil et là tu as la
chance de jouer avec un des plus grands
acteurs français Bernard
Montiel bravo
Bernard faut reconnaîre tu sais quand tu
as la chance de partager un texte avec
des légendes faut le dire on a un
extrait d'une scène toride
[Musique]
regardez
ça va pas nonou quoi espèce d'acci vous
auriez plus blesser
quelqu'un vous savez que vous êtes
superbe quand vous mettez en colère je
vais venir mais mais un petit peu en
retard commencez sans moi
oui oui oui J'arrive c'est promis je
t'embrasse
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression de voir mon enfant en
train de galocher non mais l'arrivéearé
en
SCO jet SK elle est incroyable frère
mais il a en fait je viens remarquer et
je l'adore mais il a toujours été
ringar en fait c'est un truc même
l'arrivée est folle frère l'arrivée est
folle Mar mais tu mar
mais c'est incroyable des mecs qu' slip
à côté c'est incroyable non mais ça
c'est du génie ça alors vous avez
embrassé Bernard c'est c'est c'est
le
ber le pire moment de votre carère je
garde pas un grand souvenir ah ouais je
navais je me rappelais même plus qu'il
m'avait embrassé donc m'a laissé une moi
je me rappelle même plus qu'il était
chroniqueur
ici non on l'embrasse bien entendu il
nous regarde du Point
Soleil
non mais c'est fou ça c'est fou ça c'est
c'est ça reste un bon souvenir sur le
soil tu les as quitté après 10 épisodes
je les ai quitté après 10 épisodes parce
que il m'avait vendu Pascal breton le
producteur m'avait vendu une émission
une une série sociale parce que ça
n'était pas du tout à Saint tropé
puisque c'était Jaguar et et moi je
pensais vraiment faire une série sociale
donc quand je suis arrivée là-dedans
j'ai dit non mais c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on m'a vendu sous le soleil c'est
incroyable tuétait c'est les seuls
serveurs qui roulent en Ferrari voilà
c'est ça c'est ça c'était une Dara et le
gars le gars dans le sous le soleil le
gars était servir le matin à 16h il
était chirurgien le gars il l'opér en
slip non mais c'é incroyable franchement
c'est c'est fou voilà donc et et Adeline
blondioot est arrivée sur le plateau le
producteur ne m' ne m'avait pas prévenu
qu'Adeline tournait ah ouais donc je
vois arriver Adeline et j'appelle le
producteur je dis mais pourquoi tu m'as
pas prévenu qu'Adeline venait et donc ça
fait que de fils en aiguille j'ai pas
décidé de redoubler mon contrat je les
ai quitté à la fin d'un contrat de 10
épisodes je dis mais je te rappelle que
dans deux épisodes je m'en vais il me
dit mais c'est pas possible on peut pas
tu principal j'ai dit bah oui mais je
n'ai signé que pour neuf épisodes donc
je t'annonce que je m'en vais alors
quelques années plus tard en 2005 on te
retrouve complètement métamorphosé dans
la Ferme Célébrité sur TF1 tu avais fait
la Ferme Célébrité on va voir les images
j'adorais cette émion si malorinef a
tout d'une star comme les autres en
réalité il n'en est rien derrière cette
jolie jeune femme se cache une
championne de la spiritualité une apôtre
des karmas l'eau ça va te faire du bien
ça va faire tomber visualise quand tu
prends ta douche que toutes les tensions
elles tombent voilà qu'elle tombent dans
l'eau du tout normal je te le dis Malo
parce que si tuta si tu était normal on
virait on vivrait dans un pays
complètement pacifique avec des plantes
tu es pas normal non tu pas dire que tu
es normal moi je trouve que c'est la
société qui est pas normal ah oui bon
alors le monde entier est pas normal
mais toi tu es normal je fais les choses
mais à mon rythme on est dans le sud on
est dans une ferme on n'est pas speed
quoi en 2005 la Ferme Célébrité Malorie
pourquoi tu avais disparu du du petit
écran
parce que j'ai fait mon premier enfant
ah ouais je suis tombée enceinte j'ai
fait mon mon bébé j'ai décidé de me
consacrer à mes enfants et de me
consacrer exclusivement à l'éducation de
mes enfants donc j'ai tout arrêté
progressivement j'ai fait encore de
l'art contemporain derrière j'ai fait 4
ans avec une plasticienne Nathalie talc
avec qui j'ai fait des performances dans
des musées et avec qui j'ai fait des
vidéos d'art qui ont été acheté par des
DRAC et des fras donc j'ai fait j'ai
j'ai privilégié cette relation avec
cette plasticienne et et j'ai fait un
petit peu de théâtre j'ai joué avec
Bernard Menz de pièces our dans maisis
décidé d'arrê la télévision parce
j'avais privilégé le thére en fait
est-ce que tu avais pu mettre un petit
peu d'argent de côté ou pas oh zé zé qu
tu complètement j'ai tout dépensé
j'avais gagné 200000 € en tout et pour
tout 200000 en tout et pour 200000 €
donc j'ai vécu encore un petit peu avec
cet argent et après je me suis retrouvé
au RMI puisque c'était le RMI l'ancien
RS parce qu'en plus comme disait
Benjamin cassad quand tu dévises tu
dévisses voilà c'est ça c'est
ça et et je m'assumais quand même seul
he j'aV pas de de d'hommes qui me
donnaient de l'argent j'avais pas de
mari riche j'ai toujours choisi des
hommes pauvres et et poétiques et de
beaux garçons mais qui gagnent pas bien
leur vie donc j'ai vécu une petite vie
rangée dans le 16e pendant 13 ans avec
mes enfants B non c'est bien de sortir
des des hommes beau poétiques regarde tu
vois je me reconnais complètement dans
ce que je viens de dire pvre tu vois
vraiment voilà tu vois et alors en 2012
tu lanes un appel au secours dans le
dans Le Parisien tu dévoiles que tu es
SDF depuis 1 an et que leses enfants
t'ont été retirés par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance pour être placé chez leurs
pères respectifs euh comment tu en
arrives là parce que là c'est vrai que
c'est un pour tout le monde ça été j'ai
j'ai j'ai rencontré mon le 3ème papa de
mon 3è enfant qui était algérien ouais
et ça s'est pas bien du tout passé avec
les deux premiers papas ils n'ont pas
accepté qu'un Algérien s'occupe de leurs
enfants c'est incro c'est incroyable
vraent c'est incroyable moi je suis
d'origine mon père est tunisien donc je
suis tunisienne et du côté de ma mère
ils sont italiens Corse et allemand
ouais donc oui ça fait un drôle de
mélange à la maison c'était assez épique
euh ils n'ont pas accepté que un
Algérien prenne en charge leurs enfants
et que le garçon que j'avais j'avais
choisi pour être le le père de mon
troisème enfant était un ancien Rabin ah
ouais c'est un quelqu'un qui avait
arrêté le rabinard et donc c'est un
rabin qui est qui est le père de mon
trème enfant et ils n'ont pas accepter
ce cadre de vie pour leurs enfants donc
ils m'ont attaqué et la juge leur a
donné raison c'est fou pourquoi parce
qu'ils avaient plus de moyens que moi
moi j'avais des petits moyens j'étais au
RMI enfin j'avais environ 1500 € par
mois mais ce qui est une petite une
petite Envel
mon le père de mon de mon garçon de mon
dernier garçon gagnait environ 2000 €
donc à deux on avait 3500 € mais les
pères gagnent beaucoup plus ah donc ils
étaient pas si pauvres et poétique alors
il avaientou il entre tempemps entreemps
ils avaient fait carrière le photographe
le père de mon premier enfant est
photographe il avait vendu ses photos à
François non non mais pardon